welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and this is a breakdown for the
mandalorian chapter 4 titled sanctuary
and episode that restores a tsts from
the chickens on rollerskates that they
sometimes look like and Return of the
Jedi to the evil red eyed monsters we
would probably see them as if they
walked into our acrylic arms let's
review all the influences Star Wars
Easter eggs and unresolved theories and
interesting visual details that you
might have missed in this episode and
thanks to privacy comm for sponsoring
this episode if you sign up now with
privacy comm slash new rock stars you'll
get $5 today to use on any purchase
online for read for the warning here we
go we begin on the planets organ with a
community of krill farmers the opening
shot shows these krill swimming
peacefully in a pond
notice that the farmers wear blue
inspired by the krills blue color
linking the two like the blissful krill
before the reaping these farmers also
simply just want to live kind of
underwater away from the conflict indeed
the widow and her daughter avoid that
conflict by literally hiding underwater
with these krill nifer shadows how these
farmers will score their victory later
on by tricking the walker into stepping
into this puddle and stumbling the
farmers have a harvesting droid evoke in
that whole mix of futurism and pastoral
imagery that George Lucas showed in the
first Star Wars with the moisture
vaporators
on Oklahomans farm the Raiders that
attacked him our platoon Ian's who first
showed up returned the Jedi and have
since shown up in many other
installments mando and baby yoda arrived
here seeking a remote planet as a
sanctuary Madoka Yoda a womp rat
referring to the creatures at Luke
Skywalker used to blast in beggars
Canyon on Tatooine that's not impossible
I used to bullseye womp rats in my t16
back home there they headed to a nearby
tavern where they see a wolf cat which
first appeared in Star Wars rebels
there's also a Twilight woman sitting
around their mando clocks another
warrior Kara Doon played by Gina Carano
she is a former rebel shock trooper whom
the rebels would use to keep the peace
as the Empire collapse
she mentions the Battle of Endor from
Return of the Jedi the subtle rebel
tattoo on her cheek if you look closely
she refers to the Imperials as imps
possibly a nod to these Star Wars fan
film imps of relentless fury mando is a
bounty hunter sent after her kara heads
outside mando follows her footsteps he's
in a kind of heat vision screen which
looks a lot like the kind of point of
view shots we saw in the movie predator
and then they Duke it out with some
solid fight choreography it helps when
your performer actually knows how to
fight it ends with a nod to and also
Welker
Graaff stunt film The Matrix mando and
Kara lay on the ground with guns
pointing to each other's heads just like
neo and Agent Smith there's an /b FX gap
here when mando tries torching Kara with
his wrist flamethrower the nearby ground
appears charred and Bert's cool effect
but then when it cuts back to this angle
the ground is no longer Birds no I point
this out because if you look hard enough
you can find these kind of gaffes all
over every movie and TV show even the
best of them play this episode there's
also a boom microphone that lowers down
in the shot by mistake most of the time
the editors on these things are totally
aware of these they simply just don't
have enough coverage or additional takes
or time to be able to fix them
filmmaking really is an art of doing the
best with what you got it's why many of
us will take George Lucas's imperfect
editing and the original theatrical
release of Star Wars over his attempts
in later years to fix each imperfection
with weird CGI and audio dubs and cue
them the clunky soundboard mando is
approached by two of the crow farmers
one of them played by Eugene Cordero aka
pill boy from the good place and one of
the mini comedian cameos in the show and
they beg him to protect their village
from the Raiders and teach them how to
fight this is a classic premise from
westerns and samurai films most famously
from Akira Kurosawa's the Seven Samurai
which was adapted into a ton of other
films he may have seen the Magnificent
Seven both the original and a remake a
bug's life Kurosawa was one of George
Lucas's biggest influences on the early
Star Wars films so it's cool to see the
Mandalorian go full circle with that
there was also an episode of the Clone
Wars with a similar plot season 2
episode 17 bounty hunters in which
farmers contract bali owners to help
them fend off pirates in village the
widow asks about mandos armor and he
clarifies that he does take off this
helmet sometimes just not in front of
other people and if he did he could
never put it back on mandos armor is a
not-so-subtle reflection of his
emotional armor by wearing this armor he
can mask his vulnerabilities and avoid
interpersonal distractions we nerds do
the same thing by cosplaying at cons and
then only taking off our masks when were
alone back in our hotel rooms we choose
this life this is the way other
Mandalorian characters we've seen from
other Star Wars installments people like
Sabine Boca tan Pre Vizsla Fenn rau
they're often seen without helmets but
perhaps mandos clan and this show is a
more extremist sect or maybe they just
began committing to harsher rules as a
survival tactic after the great purge
it's interesting how he tells the widow
that the man
lorian's took him in after his parents
were killed makes it sound as though he
was not a Mandalorian by blood he was an
orphan adopted by this tribe that might
help explain how the other Mandalorians
showed antagonism toward him and why it
was such a big deal that they came to
his aid before I continue thank you to
privacy icon for sponsoring this episode
privacy calm is a free service where you
use digital burner cards when you shop
online so you don't have to use your
real credit card info that keeps you
protected in case you have to go through
a shady vendor den door or an
all-powerful content subscription that
relies on you for getting you subscribe
to them so that they can squeeze another
month out of you privacy cards allow you
to control the limits on them so you can
avoid handing over the keys to your
finances every time we spend money
online so for example I've set up my
account with privacy link my bank
account and then it created this card
specifically for my monthly Netflix
subscription payment for this virtual
card I'm setting the limit just above my
monthly subscription amount so you know
when I move on with my life and I never
believe forget what I subscribe to all
the time they cannot ding me for a
second month no ven dork and overcharge
beyond the limit you've set privacy will
notify you that they blocked it because
the spending limit was already reached
see it's simple it's fast it's really
just one click they're also starting to
offer different plans there's a free
tier that lets you create up to 12 cards
a month but also there's a new pro plan
where you can get 36 cards a month and
1% cash back on your purchases and then
there's also a team's plan that's great
for small businesses just head to
privacy comm slash new rockstars to sign
up for an account it's a special treat
for my viewers new customers will
automatically get 5 dollars to spend on
your first purchase for a limited time
only
yep that's free money folks just go to
privacy comm slash new rockstars to sign
up now ok after spotting tracks made by
an ATS team and oh and caris and just
leaving but when the farmers refused
they end up agreeing to train them and
among all the farmers the best shot is
the widow so what is this woman's story
is this just another example of the kind
of Nancy wheeler perfect aim trope or
this woman have been a former rebel or
Imperial soldier now just trying to
settle down in a simpler life let me
know what you think this woman's story
is in the comments below mando and Cara
attacked the Raiders camp to try to lure
out the ATS tee and when it rises this
thing is freaking terrifying the
production designers illuminated the
cockpit with red light to make the
illusion of glowing red eyes giving it
an animalistic quality this episode was
directed by Bryce Dallas Howard actress
and daughter of solo star wars story
director Ron Howard
but bryce dallas howard seems to be
drawing more on the visuals from the
movies shoes in the Jurassic Park films
the way the 80s tese Thompson from the
distance and its ways from side to side
and it bends the trees as it looms into
view the way they look down to the track
as if it was a t-rex track yeah this
threat it's definitely more organic than
industrial like the t-rex and Rasik Park
it is an unholy union of nature intact
also worth noting the Jurassic Park is a
story about cloning and genetic
engineering keep that in mind for later
in Empire Strikes Back the production
designers based the walkers on the
tripods from HT wells War of the Worlds
this imagery restores that sense of
terror that we were always meant to feel
when we look up at these things now the
fact that this atest is being operated
by clawed Raiders shows us just how
scary this world now is that the Empire
has collapsed and the imperial
technology has fallen into the wrong
hands I guess it was always in the wrong
hands but like uninformed hands this
could shed light on what's going on with
Werner Herzog's character and dr.
Pershing could they be using a very
valuable technology from the Empire's
early days cloning or a similar evil
purpose watch last week's episode for my
theory on what they could be doing with
baby Yoda so they bring down the ETS tea
and peace settles in the village maybe
otis spits out a frog when the kids are
grossed out the little detail that shows
in learning a bit of humanity just by
seeing raw human reactions for him
gobbled down a whole frog in front of
mando like it was nothing maybe because
man does helmet masked reaction so baby
oda doesn't just need protection it
needs a human connection in order to
grow but another one of grief Targa's
bounty hunters tracks him down holding a
fob with a menacing blinking red lights
to me this light evokes the tracker to
the bounty hunter Anton Chigurh used in
No Country for Old Men - something about
that blinking red light terrifying so
they depart once more and when the girl
hugs maybe Oh - goodbye notice how it
releases this along with the baby sounds
I just love how much expression the baby
Yoda puppeteers are getting from its
ears this is why if you want real eg
farewell style emotion from non-human
characters
you always go practical follow me on
social set ei vas and subscribe to new
Rockstar Star Wars podcast WikiLeaks for
more of these breakdowns in audio form
thanks for watching
[Music]